I'm ready ready to drink tonight
director bong joon-ho sweeping the 92nd
Academy Awards and hilariously showing
us all that he clearly knows how to
celebrate the South Korean filmmaker
walked away with four Academy Awards Oh
Joon ho
including Best Original Screenplay Best
International feature film Best Director
and Best Picture and the Oscar goes to
parasite
[Applause]
to win the Oscar all our loving
crewmembers and cast members are here
with us today please send a round of
applause to the actors and crew members
of parasite parasite
after winning best international feature
I thought I was done for the day and was
ready to relax my only wish for mommy
and me and Todd and Sam great directors
that I admire if the Academy allows I
would like to get a Texas Chainsaw split
the Oscar trophy into five and share it
would share it with all of you thank you
I really dream come to the next timoni
thank you et caught up with a multi
Oscar winner at the Governor's Ball
where he dished on his big night
director bomb how about this are you
double fisting tonight I don't know how
many trophy I have so how much of a
surprise was it when number one you
heard your name for Best Director number
two best picture from all of you
now all the theater Gino and Jenny
Johnny Simon will test on your journey
she wasn't there the last year I didn't
expect it at all even now it still feels
so surreal you made history tonight
the first it's a history but I never
intended that we just made a movie as
always it just happened became a
movement really do you think yeah thank
you
combo you go get your own Jang Yoon ha
watch Amitabh Bachchan Juanito tun Lucia
gazpacho decimeter Castle the world
won't change overnight because of this
but I hope this provides a small spark
you told us on the red carpet that
you're just being crazy
so how FN crazy are you gonna be tonight
[Laughter]
I'm already crazy and I don't know how
much I can drink it tonight but I will
try my best as much as possible yeah
when when the crowd started saying in
let you all finish and put them put the
mics back on booth what was that moment
like an eagerly good you can check out a
producer a girl to Mike Rinder oversaw
the chair actually in the Tom and
Kristen you mean
1000 changing on your corn the matching
bag every song Cajon they meet at 10:00
and John a cost and takasi the job talk
about more MIDI so much estimate I stand
there so when our executive producer try
to speak and the mic went down Tom Hanks
was the first one to instigate the
backup of that so that was great I wish
some Gamow had a chance to talk but that
was the only shame in speech thank you
so much congratulations you all have a
wonderful time tonight
[Music]